great so welcome today there's we're a
small group maybe we'll be a larger
group as we go along we're gonna talk
about Career Management I titled this 18
steps to empowerment I think there's
more than 18 steps actually but I
decided to choose some number that was
attractive in some way and 18 is a
symbol for life so I wanted to tie that
in as well so welcome we're gonna give
it like another minute or so for people
to join and and to make sure I'm
technologically on top of things and
actually recording this which I think I
am
and while we're waiting I since there's
only five of us if you could share where
you're from basically in what you're
studying right now and I will unmute
Daniel I'm from Los Angeles and I just
got done with the full stack nano degree
and I'm starting the data structures and
algorithms hey I saw you on the AMA the
other day yeah yeah nice to see you
again great and arena hi everyone I'm
arena I'm based in Edinburgh Scotland so
a bit further from the majority of you
probably and I'm late at night yeah it
is quite a bit that's okay I'm an early
and midnight an early bird and a night
owl so I I do both and and I'm currently
studying predictive analytics oh very
cool okay excellent
and hurry everyone hurry I'm from
Toronto Canada
so I am done with the business analytics
nano degree and I have started the date
on with
excellent cool and Zachary oops
find out mutant Zachary yeah nope I I'm
just about halfway into the deep
learning degree it's a total change for
me
Oh what are you coming from private
tutoring in what subjects like test prep
math and English I'm doing that for 15
years
excellent and where are you located
Cambridge Massachusetts okay good so we
have one holdout from Canada and and
Edinboro and other than that the United
States is representing right now anyway
welcome everybody my name is Andrea Nia
and I am technologically challenged to
do these webinars so you just have to
bear with me as I go slowly clicking on
things okay let's see this is not moving
to the next one okay I live in Portland
Oregon and I'm an ACC certified coach I
focused mainly on tech people basically
and creative people my background has
been in filmmaking for a long time
before I got into coaching and I
and you'll see as we go through this I
care a lot about storytelling and how
you tell your story basically and and
also about how you you maximize that
sort of impact for people so that's part
of what we'll be talking about today
about managing a career and personally I
believe I've had kind of I would say
three careers so I understand about
career changing and how you how you
manage that basically and that careers
versus jobs which is one of the things I
wanted to talk about their different
careers you're more invested in
basically and a job is something you do
for money I so that getting kids today's
agenda we're gonna talk a little bit
about job versus career but mainly we're
just gonna talk about what the mindset
is when you take on a new career or you
take on a new job what you should keep
in mind and and how to strategize
starting that job on the right foot to
enable you to get what you need out of
the job but they need that something
also you know that's it's it's a
economic relationship however keeping in
mind goals from the from the outset
basically can set you up for success so
what are the first jobs we're going to
talk about that and then we're gonna
talk about a little bit of branding
basically and when I say personal
branding what I mean is getting in touch
with value that you have to offer and
being able to articulate it to others
and also to be able to commit to it
yourself basically - - so this isn't
about creating something it's like oh
I'm gonna be a brand that wears black
t-shirts and and jeans and I'm going to
have this relaxed attitude you know that
creating an image basically when it
isn't something natural to
I'm talking about trying to get in touch
with what is natural to you and then
amplifying okay so I just want to
double-check you're seeing my you're
seeing something that says first days
now and just making sure that where I
have two screens up and making sure
you're seeing the proper screen is that
correct anybody can just say something
in the chat room or raise their hand and
say yes
Daniel are you seeing first days
yes okay good okay this one and make
sure and by the way feel free to unmute
yourself and feel free to to be
interactive with this I am NOT an
extremely formal person and I like the
Socratic method and I like to be
interrupted okay so I want to talk about
when you come on a job first things that
you should do some of these may be
totally obvious some of them may not be
until you're there and realize oh my god
this is an entirely new social structure
basically and I need to figure out how
it works so one of the first things to
do is of course review the role that
you're actually going to be taking on
identifying who the key stakeholders are
these may be internal or external ones
but the ones that you're going to have
to be dealing with trying to define and
this is even before you get there what
are the main challenges that are going
to be in front of you for your job and
opportunities meeting your new teams and
and then just sort of the practicalities
of things
so one of the things that I recommend
first to do and this can be of course
before you get there is to familiarize
yourself with both the formal and the
informal hierarchy of the place who's
who who does what identify the key
decision-makers and regardless of where
you work you need to know where where
everybody who plays a part in your
experience is and and how they how they
can affect you basically you also need
to know all about the products that the
company is selling and the services and
how they are valuing business
performance basically each company has
its own language because its own jargon
that it uses basically and that's
something also at the very beginning you
need to get a handle on basically
understanding keywords and phrases then
the other thing that I would say is
really diving into the corporate
strategy and mission of the company you
are joining a organization joining a
workforce in some way you have to
understand what the underlying
philosophy is one so that you can master
it and you can understand it and to take
advantage of it
and three make sure that you're actually
aligned with it it's possible that
you're not I in taking a job and if you
know that from the get-go that there's
something that's a little off that
you're not relating to this is actually
a good sign right at the beginning that
this may not be a place that you will be
growing with and in wanting to stay with
a long time so it
takes a lot for a company to come up
with their mission statement in the
corporate strategy it takes a lot of
work and a lot of thought and if it's
something that you are not you know
relating to very well basically this is
actually you know a sign that you need
to think this might have not been the
best mix for you hold on one second I
need to
admit people
[Music]
welcome Kinnear hi welcome
I can hear where are you located
I'm from Istanbul Turkey Istanbul okay
fantastic and balanc you just joined us
also where are you located sure I was I
was wondering if Blanca could also speak
up who just joined me well Blanca where
are you located okay maybe she hears us
maybe she doesn't okay anyway welcome to
both of you we're talking about managing
your careers today and the first things
that I wanted to talk about about this
that we're getting into is knowing the
company that you're joining deeply and
and connecting with their jargon and
their corporate strategy and if you're
not connecting with their mission
statement or the corporate strategy
that's a good red flag for you to pay
attention to as you go along because
that's that's something that's not
necessarily going to change okay one
second why is this not moving on for the
next one okay so when you begin there's
a few things to think about setting
goals basically everything kind of
everything comes down to setting goals
but we can talk about what kind of goals
to set one is to set eight products and
they said it's based on eight items
business priorities these are we're
gonna be talking about winds things that
are the most the most important for your
position things to get done basically
what you've been hired for
another thing we're going to talk about
is building your personal brand I
alluded to this a little bit earlier
we're actually going to do a little
breakout exercise where we can talk to
each other about what our personal brand
is and I'll give you some wording to
talk about that identifying personal
development opportunities in education
all of you obviously since you are
taking classes at Udacity you have
figured out that you need to invest in
yourself and that key be learning and
keeping up on the latest developments as
well as developing yourself as a person
I would say emotional intelligence is
actually one of the prime things that
you could invest in making sure that you
are strong in that area looking for
those opportunities when you're at a job
but even regardless of a job career-wise
these are the types of things that are
important for you to keep working on
basically an education doesn't stop as
all of you know at college or grad
school or high school wherever you
whatever you stopped formal education
education continues as we continue to
learn about ourselves and as we continue
to learn about how to maximize our
effect on others as well creating your
vision for the role taking the time to
actually imagine what it is that you
want from the experience who you want to
be in that experience but you want to
achieve in that experience one of the
most important things that I you know
every day I'm talking to people who are
working on their resume and working on
their presentation speech basically
30-second presentations region and it's
very difficult for people to be able to
speak about themselves and to be able to
and it's not show off but be able to
encapsulate what their achievements are
and achievements are both soft and hard
skill Affairs
they are hey I did this activity and we
became 20% more profitable yay that's a
that's a real straightforward
results-oriented achievement but it
could also be I was really good at
communication in some fashion basically
and was able to bring a multicultural
team together to work towards a goal
successfully this is a soft skill when
you create your vision for what you want
from the role that you're taking go
deeper than just I want to get their
website up and running you know that is
important of course and we will talk
about breaking down smaller and smaller
goals within that but think about also
soft skills that you want to develop
during this time do you want to be a
team leader during this time basically
or do you want to be a a good team
member you know and be a responsive team
member how do you want to present
yourself basically so that when you walk
out of this job whatever the job is and
on to the next one or you get promoted
you had a sense at the beginning of what
the goal what the the vision I says the
vision of the role was and whether you
fulfilled that vision so the deeper the
vision the more detailed the vision the
more successful you'll you'll be able to
move on to the next thing basically and
being able to point to what your
achievements were there's a mindfulness
to what I'm talking about basically
versus a show up and do your job I doing
being engaged in a career and in
personal and professional development in
that way I is to great degree about
being mindful mindful of what your goals
are mindful of who you are as you act in
that circumstance
and mindful of what it is that you then
you have achieved look for a mentor and
I this is one of those wonderful things
that when it happens it can be a godsend
and you can have mentors all different
types of mentors you could have a mentor
that that helps you with your finances a
mentor that helps you with your romantic
relationships a mentor who helps you in
your professional development Mentors
but they're hard to find and you have to
actually look for them you have to
actually propose it to people at times
and maybe even be formal about it saying
I would love for you to mentor me it's
finding the right person also who's
willing to invest and be an advocate of
you and to see your potential basically
and want to cultivate it mentors can be
of any age they can be if people that
are what you would consider your peers
age was just because they know something
more about something that you don't know
basically and they're willing to invest
in you in that way and obviously they
can be older but looking for a mentor
and this is something to do both at a
job potentially if it's a you know big
enough company and also outside of a job
this is a way to start to get get
yourself a feedback loop as to what are
you doing right what could be adjusted
perhaps getting some perspective that's
outside of your own head basically that
hopefully has a a larger vision you know
then than where you are yet and can help
guide you so a mentor is a lovely thing
to get and can be very helpful in your
career the people that I know who have
had mentors in their lives especially at
the beginning of doing a career
transition or getting into
getting into a career to begin with have
so have such a better time of it
basically I think partially because
there's a sense of not being alone and
partially because the mentor actually
helps in some way so this is something
to look for it's a delicate thing I
would say to ask for in somebody it's it
has to be the right mix you have to have
the right chemistry basically but and
people can say no of course and some
people know how to be mentors and some
people maybe don't understand what it is
the more you're articulate about what it
is you want and that's why I mentioned
you could have mentors about your you
know romantic relationships you could
have mentors about finances different
different aspects the more you're clear
on what it is you're looking for from
them what area of expertise the easier
it is for somebody to respond and say
yes I can do that so it's like it's like
asking for help you know the more you
can say hey please move this from A to B
as opposed to I need help it's much
easier for someone to say it sure I'll
help you move from A to B asking for
help is just so so vague basically so
personal brand we'll talk about this a
little step-by-step one second
okay so first thing is determine and
prioritize your values and your passions
something I want you to keep in mind
when I say that oftentimes people
immediately go to their resume and start
explaining their resume like I did this
I did that I was here you know at this
job and then I moved to that job that is
that's not what it is at all actually it
is about what it is that drove you maybe
initially when you were four years old
who knows when when the vision of what
has driven you started there was one
fellow we just talked to here let's see
if I get your name right and of course I
can't move things well to see the
gentleman who Zachary who was a a tutor
preparing people for
nice tests right mm-hmm
yeah and and now and now what area are
you moving into probably artificial
intelligence I hope or learning
something like that okay
I'm gonna play with you for a second
okay if you come on what is it about
that that's driving you to get into
artificial intelligence I think I've
been fascinated with it for a long long
long time and it seems like there are
things happening in the field right now
that make that make it possible to do
stuff that couldn't been done even two
or three years ago so that's exciting to
me okay I have a question for you about
what you went into originally which is
you know helping people standard up with
their standardized test preparation
version
AI I would know what you think is
similar about those two activities I
guess the thing I think about a lot when
is is about understanding deeper
structures and how people are thinking
or processing information which matches
what a what a neural network would do
it's it's a different kind of processing
but it's still about having insight into
translating experience into action okay
abstract that's a little abstract
what's the I'm gonna I'm playing with
you so so today I'm sure for everybody
of what I'm talking about when is the
first time that you experienced this
sort of interest in and and how people
interact in that way how neural networks
work as far as education goes I mean
it's it's it's been 20 years bust it's
it's a my whole undergraduate I took
computer science and psychology and
trying to sort of find the overlap
between those two things okay excellent
and how do you how did you come up with
computer science and psychology what
what was it was exciting that put those
two things together Wow I mean they're
they're they were the two best programs
at my school partly but also
I wanted to study cognitive science and
they didn't have it I just psychology's
about how human mind works and computer
science is a different way of sort of
structuring information and there's
overlaps between the two that are kind
of really helpful and interesting okay
so ya know they by the way this sort of
inquiry can be kind of tough to do okay
because and and I'm not saying that
we've gotten to the conclusion of it yet
but I'm using you as an example in this
way and sharing with you some of the
inquiry that goes into it in the sense
that what we're trying to pull out is
what is your thematic in life and absent
relates to your professional drive
teaching teaching yeah so teaching you
know it's people teaching computers yeah
it is and why you like teaching you
think why do I like it yeah I mean it's
it's incredibly fascinating it's it's
probably I mean education is really I
think the tool to heal the world if
that's a way to put it
okay thank you I think you care about
that oh absolutely yeah okay so this is
your method to engage and heal the world
is through education that can manifest
its its manifest as a teacher or
manifest as a teaching a computer how to
teach yeah okay so
I lack may hear this and I hope all of
you hear this to some degree that that
that is like a thematic in some way okay
that's tapping into the the greater
thing that now if you introduced
yourself to me and you told me a little
bit about what drove you basically from
the beginning that you want to affect
people and that you want to do that
through education whether it be neural
networks or teaching people how to take
tests that that wasn't very articulate
for whatever it that can be wordsmith
that that systems you know being able to
present systems and helping people learn
through those systems as well is is an
important value and one that you you're
driven to do does that make sense that's
great
Zack first of all yeah that's actually
really a that's succinct and wonderful
thank you okay so this is this is what
we want to do all of us basically to get
to that as close as you can to the sort
of original kernel of what it is that is
driving you through all these different
careers that you might have through all
these different jobs that you might have
some of which will be aligned I with
that mission and some which may not be
aligned and that's usually the ones you
you leave faster basically so in step
two defining your key traits I think we
did some of that in in this developing
your personal image so this is one that
that for me this is always a tough one
I've it's you know there are people that
and you know them Steve Jobs is an
excellent example of one he figured out
an image and he stuck with it basically
and it was comfortable for him who's the
other guy the Facebook guy Zuckerberg
another one
sited t-shirts was his thing stuck with
it whatever it is whatever your image is
that you want to read it has to be
something that you are comfortable with
but it also has to be a a decision if
you decide you want to be known as as as
the sloppy guy the one who doesn't care
okay but just know that you're making
that decision you're making that choice
that that is going to be your personal
brand your image so I'm not saying go
and create one go and create you know
dress in fancy professional gear you
know all day and and wear a lot of
makeup or or only dress in three-piece
suits that may not be what's natural for
you but make a choice as to how you want
to present for yourself I remember as I
was growing up I was always told dress
not for the position that you're in but
for the position you were aspire to
I sort of agree with that to some degree
you know that you want to you want to
inspire yourself basically with your
dress that you feel comfortable and good
and strong but the main point of number
three is make some decision about this
and be consistent about it as well
whatever it is that you choosing and I'm
not encouraging you to choose to be a
slob
and and say well I chose it that's what
it is you know consider if it's the
image that you want that you think is
comfortable and good for yourself and
will communicate what what is a value to
you as well so yes if being a slob is a
value to you then I guess that is right
it's such an importance does it is it
important because it implies that we are
consistent or we are trusted with our
consistent image is that why is so
important it's important because it's
what's doing what you're doing to
represent yourself basically and so I'm
not saying if you wear a different color
t-shirt every day that that's somehow
not consistent and and that then people
won't know what to expect from you what
I'm saying is that making a choice as to
how you're going to present yourself and
committing to that committing to that
vision of yourself which could have
great great variety within it so I'm not
saying it has to be a t-shirt every day
it has to be like Steve Jobs and his
turtleneck but but it does have to be a
choice and it is part of how people will
react to you
your smells your your clothing basically
your personal hygiene these are how
people are there were human beings and
we're animals basically this is how we
relate to each other we see what's on
the surface or we smell what's on the
surface and we have reactions to it and
you want to minimize negative reactions
and maximize positive ones and
consistent ones that I can recognize you
as that that this is part of your brand
basically I have a friend who is used to
make clothing for herself she is she is
a beautiful woman who who is always
impeccably dressed always her hair is
done always her clothing is perfectly
aligned and it's not that she has great
wealth or or even I would say like that
I think her taste is that good but boy
does she know how to put herself
together and is always in this
presentable mode she has decided that
her personal brand is that basically
that she will dress professionally even
to go play tennis on some level it's
it's always a put together image I'm not
saying that that should be yours what
I'm saying is that she's made it clear
um what to expect from her basically and
how she shows up for herself and and
therefore how she's showing up for
others as well does that answer your
question Kinnear yes you're welcome any
let's take a moment any other questions
so far about what I've talked about yeah
you can just unmute yourself enough so
another thing is building your online
presence so there's there's um LinkedIn
being the most important aspect of this
as far as professional presence goes via
tub for many of you is another area
that's important to be able to talk
through projects that you have and to be
able to present yourself if you're a UX
designer really being able to show that
you have some sort of vision basically
when you create design and that people
can and you can walk them through what
this is um those are three areas
potentially that that need to be
developed but you also have to consider
other things that you might be doing
online on LinkedIn you know are you
making comments and are they thoughtful
comments on thought-leaders sites
basically or you know following what
they're saying are you starting to
become a known quantity in online you
know whether in LinkedIn or professional
groups in some way and what are what is
your online presence are you the person
that just likes everything are you the
person that never says anything are you
the person that always makes a you know
intelligent kind of interesting comment
or funny comment are you are you the
person that really connects with a lot
of people in your arena at your area of
expertise you know and becomes a
connector type person and says oh by the
way you should know Jake he's doing
something interesting while you're
talking to Jill so what is your your
online presence basically and building
one that you respect and that you feel
comfortable maintaining as well so I'm
not talking about the make sure you
don't put crap on Facebook that
everybody can see and you know that some
of these things are obvious on some
level of you know keep your privacy and
the things that are not about your
professional persona I keep them keep
them offline keep them not easily found
basically build the persona that you
respect in your professional life and
make sure that that is what people see
follow in the footsteps of an expert you
know today this is a way that you can
get a sense of this how you sort of want
to use Steve Jobs as an example but I
can use anyone basically um the point is
if there is somebody that you think is
fabulous in your world whatever world
you know whether it's development that
you're in or education whatever the the
area might be see how they got to where
they got how are they presenting
themselves even professionally are they
putting information out there for people
for free are they how do how do they
hold themselves how do they present
themselves it's okay to look at people
who have come before and to as you're
modeling yourself take some of the best
from other people and and model yourself
in that way still do it you're on your
own terms in your own way but but it's
ok to to model yourself on something
that you respect in someone else and
especially someone in the field that you
are going into ok so I want us to do an
exercise that we're going to since we're
a group of eight people we can all do it
together this phrase here bit you see
give me one second do something here
I'm not presenting this as like this is
the beginning all end all one to use
okay but but it gives us a starting
ground basically so I want to give you
an example of mine and I'm gonna say it
a little bit slowly okay and I want you
to look at this phrase here which is
actually three phrases and start to
think of how you would fill this in okay
so I will give you mine so we get an
example okay and and by the way whatever
comes up quickly go with that don't
don't overthink this one too much I
think I wrote mine in like the whole of
15 seconds when I was just thinking
about it okay
I didn't wordsmith it I didn't play with
it I just said okay is it so I said for
mine I use my sense of humor and warm
personality for winning clients known
for intelligent and strategic thinking
using my experience as a filmmaker and a
storyteller I help others tell their
stories by providing career coaching
advice
so I use my humor and warm personality I
use something about my personality
basically
and for what purpose
changing the world maybe I don't know
and what am i known for something I want
you all to to think about about this
known for thing and about this exercise
in general which we will will get to
really quickly and and and sort of
practice on each other if you don't have
a clear sense of yourself or you haven't
had the opportunity to go through what
Zack and I were just doing basically
with somebody a really great way to
start to figure out what your personal
brand is is to interview people who know
you well your mother your father your
brother your sister your best friend
your your your really smart
maybe not so best friend who like who
understands you interview them and ask
them who they think you are
what is that when I'm getting to this
phrase of what am i known for basically
listen for those key words that they use
probably there will be a consistent
story that comes out of this as to who
you are
and that's you know it's not that
everybody is is right and and somehow
and you may disagree with this you need
to have some sense of what you are
perceived as as well that doesn't mean
that it has to be who you are and what
you say it you're known for is based on
their words however this is an excellent
place to to jump off from basically and
to take seriously what it is that people
say about you I think oftentimes people
don't value themselves as much as others
can value them and so this is also a
good exercise in hearing you know what
you are valued for and also maybe what
you aren't valued for you know maybe
maybe things that you do that
you're not so proud of and it'll give
you feedback that way as well so in the
last one
is using what you know your computer
skills
I don't know using something basically
some skill that you have I provide
something
[Music]
for others basically
very good but mine was using my
experience as a filmmaker and
storyteller I help others tell their
stories by providing career coaching
advice
so as you can see I put in a lot of
words between the comments there it
wasn't just one word even though that's
what the space I'm giving right now okay
okay we are
all
okay I've just invited all of you to
join a group so please join
have one group
you
come on together yes okay there so I'd
like you to the exercise that we had
which I guess you can't see at the same
time as as we can see ourselves is that
right
yeah you can't see my screen right you
can still share it you should be able to
share it yeah
okay let me give me one second yeah okay
so you can you all see that now yet no
not yet
okay well hopefully you wrote down a
couple little notes right sorry
yeah I'm not seeing it so I'm not sure I
can see all your lovely faces so that's
a good thing what I'd like us to do is
I'd like this to try a little bit of
this ourselves be able to present
ourselves basically so um who would like
to go first
okay excellent
that's that is if I understood the whole
exercise correctly so for the first
phrase I guess I said something in the
lines of I use my analytical thinking
and ability to motivate to drive action
okay it may be less person action is a
little like not your very task range
okay no no that actually is great that
you love seeing something finished okay
that that may be part of what it is to
folks and I keep going sorry in my
second line I couldn't quite understand
the second part really what we're
supposed to be doing but it's something
in the lines that I'm known for being
task orientated
yes okay and and I don't know do we need
to put - no not necessarily
I just did it with - because ya might
think of another kind of yeah and then
and the last part is more about what I
do currently in my job I guess so it's
it's something in the lines of I use my
financial reporting skills in order to
put together reports by providing which
then provides insights to the
stakeholders in order for them to make
decisions but I probably need to phrase
that a bit better I think that can be
wordsmith and the the providing reports
isn't a great landing place it's more
that I create these reports in order to
provide some sort of what kind of
analysis you know and what kind of
insights I for decision makers - to
really make the best decision possible
and moving forward you know that's
that's that's where your sweet spot is
basic okay let's do another one
Daniel you wanted to go oh sure
I use my intellect and knowledge to
create high quality software known for
efficiency and quality I use a
systematic detail-oriented okay first of
all good use of English high quality
versus quality and you didn't but but
I'm going to say a little vague okay
okay we want it we want to ground this
in in something specific as well okay I
don't want to be able to say Daniel and
Kinnear you know something you have
about the same story you know I want to
remember something more so for example
with arena task-oriented really came out
as as something that she is all about we
could even get into more detail about
that perhaps
finding one or two keywords that are
unique to you and to tie in to what your
experiences have been is great because
then that's what you're delivering okay
does that make sense so I'm being I'm
being tough on this because to elevate
and to be able to communicate a unique
story to people right okay that it will
come back to you Kinnear yeah I couldn't
write anything down because I'm not able
right now but I made up my reasoning and
imagination to mmm to build higher
valued products known for my and yeah
thank you know for my biased action and
actual prioritization can I show you
think can I see bigger please let's see
I think that's in the chat room that he
put that up which was yes mm-hmm if you
click open the chat room it should be
there yes creating I really do products
known for my strong by abstraction and
and my accurate prioritization skills
using my project management and product
management skills
I provide really by creating products
that give high relie to consumers
kind of consumers okay
accurate is the word that I got out of
that mm-hmm
as my takeaway that you were to accuracy
basically and I asked about what kind of
consumers because again that was a vague
term and and I it wasn't grounded yet so
that I understood what you were about in
that way um so I think pretty good job I
think this is one of those that you can
go even like why why is accuracy even
important to you because I think and
[Music]
analytical projects for example I was
working for ice cream job project
managers for opening a second facility
in Turkey and then I project I made a
forecasting model yeah resulted in the
highest accuracy of all time for 25 per
25 years of brand in Turkey and then the
project came in successful because of
paneer okay you get it okay they you can
tell that story you know some variation
on that story right how accuracy
something that you are passionate about
accuracy also brings success to the
people you bring those skills to
it brings success by for example being
able to have the accurate numbers in
opening an ice cream
what is it Factory sorry Factory and in
in all Unilever experienced the most
accurate predictions basically of what
it would take to open it and it became a
successful opening I think it's a great
example mainly in that it taps into what
is important to you so accuracy being
the key word to build to build this
statement around
thank you you're welcome
Hari would you like to go yes I'll go so
I wrote I use my analytical and
problem-solving skills for solving
business problems at scale known for
looking at the big picture as well as
focusing on the details I ensure that
the needs of all stakeholders are met
and using my technical expertise and
wide-ranging to my knowledge I give
strategic insights to key
decision-makers wide-ranging what kind
of knowledge domain domain knowledge
domain knowledge what is your day
education as well as retail so I worked
in both I have and I have a consulting
background as well across different
industries okay you're being a little
vague I'm going to say okay you're
falling into Daniels category of saying
saying words that sound that I'm not
saying they're not you okay we but this
needs to get grounded in something a
little deeper right hey and in
not clear on which thing it is right now
when I'm listening to you sorted so I'm
not gonna grab on to it but but I'm
gonna challenge you to find what that is
it may be the domains it may be
something about the domains that drives
you so I thought about that it sounded
like you were going in several
directions though that you know dealing
with stakeholders being a good thing big
big project you know small details being
another aspect of it your domains which
I had to ask you about maybe is another
aspect of it I'm not quite sure right
one of these are a combination of these
so the idea would be to focus on a few
rather than well get clear on the most
important one and that little attic will
come through the others as well garden
okay thank you
okay um Blanca would you like to go I'm
not sure if you can hear I saw that you
had written in before
I'm gonna unmute you but but I'm
sure if she can talk okay it's not
working okay we're gonna go back to
regular heiio any questions now that I
have you all up though at this point
No okay
somehow there's still are we still all
together okay okay can everybody hear me
still yes okay great give me one second
then okay so something else I'd like
this o is not going that fast there
there so one of the things I also want
you to consider when you're joining a
job and this thing on the right side is
called a stakeholder map and you can go
online and look for a stakeholder map
yourself this is just an example of one
but this is about when you're in a new
workplace or it you're at one right now
what are the Alliance's that you need to
create to create to make yourself
successful to be able to see through
your goals and one this is just a
breakdown to give you some sense of this
basically some of these people that you
have to work with are not so important
basically and all you need to do is show
consideration for them so in this case
the bottom right are those types of
people for this particular job that I'm
just giving as an example okay start the
main point of this is start to identify
who is important to you basically where
your interest should live where their
interests lie as well getting a sense of
what's driving them
as well as what's driving yourself but
and creating this little graph is kind
of an interesting way to start thinking
about what are the priorities here
basically what are the priorities of all
these different people that I work with
and how can i how can I make their lives
better or simpler not just my own
move this thing give me a second here
there
okay so in also setting up I beginning
to work somewhere we want to establish
the a item priorities so this is
breaking things down into the first
twelve to eighteen months the major
things that you need to identify that
you need to accomplish basically during
that time identifying the center of
gravity this is looking for where can
you get winds early basically let's say
that you are your goal is to launch a
website for example that that's that's
the project basically that the end
project but it's a big complicated
website figuring out what are the these
smaller steps along the way that are
going to be visible that you can that
that are benchmarks basically so that
then this isn't just project management
it's it's being a little more strategic
not just saying oh that's the first one
that needs to be done of course but
looking for what are the forms that what
can be pointed to is like this has been
accomplished in some fashion and this is
this is a win basically and this is the
progress that I'm trying to make towards
launching the website it may be simply
enough buying the domain okay or locking
up fifteen domains because they haven't
made the decision what domain to use yet
and how you went about like deciding
which domains are good for them to lock
down so
initiating pilot projects this is all
about also ownership basically getting a
sense of what what is it that you want
to win basically and structuring it as
as a project basically as as something
that you can look to as an
accomplishment along the way so one of
the challenges I told you in working
with people on their resumes is getting
a sense of what their achievements are
some people are like they don't
understand what their achievements are
at all and I I have the experience of
being on jobs where I've written down
all the different achievements my god
you forget them like so quickly also you
like within three months you could
forget what you did three months ago and
forget that it was an achievement and I
do recommend writing these things down
as you go because if you're anything
like me that the memory of like oh yeah
I did that becomes not a big deal but if
the truth is they can be big deals you
know to show off and so writing these
things down basically but thinking of
them all as little projects little
projects how did you go about them what
did you achieve what kind of results did
you get keeping that on mind from the
very beginning basically I will serve
you will serve you really well
so ultimately um some of what I just
need to move one thing down so I can see
some of what I am referring to for a lot
of this is about goal-setting basically
this is actually a logo that the army
uses of the Armed Forces in the United
States use when they're setting goals so
getting very specific about what you
want to do making sure that you set some
sort of measurement in mind to begin
with as to when you will know you have
success making sure that it's achievable
so understanding what's in your power to
create and what will not be in your
power to create so adjusting based on
that being as the next one says is
realistic basically but I would add with
realistic it's it's also relevant
relevant or realistic you could do you
know is this relevant to what you want
to achieve
it may be realistic but is it also
something that is in the purview that
you that's of interest to you basically
and the other thing is about timing
really having a sense of if you're
taking on a new job what is the timing
of getting things accomplished basically
at that place or how long do you even
want to be there you know maybe you only
want to be there a year and you're
setting out the goals for yourself
during that time period including I want
to get all of this done by this time and
I want to look for a new job three
months to the end of that and I will
have had extra show before I start
looking for this new job that will be
maybe more aligned with whatever my
vision is so this is just stuff to keep
in mind as far as goals go and about
being as specific as you can about goals
when you take on a new job and and as
you move forward in your career I think
there's a I'm not recommending this
necessarily but I have a friend who he
went to graduate
school with me for filmmaking he came
out of news world actually I decided
Hollywood wasn't for him and moved back
to New York and started working for
emergency services in the city of New
York and was there during 9/11 and now
he works for FEMA he loves what he's
doing basically he is he's found his
place but this man what was always
interesting to me about him and I think
it was a great lesson for for people is
that no sooner would he land someplace
then he would start looking for what's
next how where am I going next with this
what do I need out of it to get to that
next thing basically he's managed
incredible multiple careers in doing
this and I think is now like you know
pretty satisfied actually with where he
is and what he's doing at this point but
I always respected the fact that he
didn't
it was there was always a bigger picture
in mind as to where he was going and he
was never going to just be do the job
and and have the loyalty to the company
or put all of those things as more of a
priority then him moving towards a
vision of what he wanted for himself and
he took missteps along the way and he
took great steps along the way that made
it happen but keeping that in mind
staying a little uncomfortable as you
move forward in your career a little
uncomfortable somewhere unless you're
getting everything that you want from
that place basically keep that sense of
discomfort to keep driving you forward
so that you can you can reach your goals
complacency is death
[Music]
okay so Oh a couple other things this is
just a reference book that great to
learn great to learn from basically if
you are interested in knowing more about
what I just talked about I've taken a
few ideas from him basically so I wanted
to reference him and I wanted to know if
there's any questions now or any any
sort of aundrea
you just explained so much how am I
supposed to keep up with that yes Arina
and I'm always quite curious about like
at the moment I'm really I'm investing a
lot of time and like learning or finding
out how to get a mentor and I have tried
with several people and some people say
yeah let's go for coffee well when we
were able to go for coffee but then they
obviously get too busy or something
happens and I never get any replies back
or something like that so I'm still I'm
still trying but keep trying so what's
happening you're asking for coffee but
then you're not actually meeting yeah
you should give it in those lines or
yeah so one of the things that's
important to do in choosing the person
is to find something that you have in
common with them to begin with this is
true for informational interviews also
you want to draw you know the lines
together maybe you grew up in the same
area maybe went to the same school maybe
your children are doing something in
common who knows what it is but you want
to make sure that that commonality is
put forefront so that they feel a little
bit more of a connection the other thing
right you're in charge of making sure
the coffee happens whether it's an
informational interview or asking for a
mentorship you're in charge you're
setting the agenda
and you're you're running the meeting
okay you're interviewing them
essentially for this position as well is
something you should consider that it's
not them interviewing you do I want to
do it but you interviewing them are you
capable of doing this would you like to
do this are you
I I really want to learn from you are
you willing to share you know so I what
I would challenge you with arena is is
just a little bit of a mind shift with
this okay that this is something that
you want and you're interviewing these
people to see if they can help you with
it okay sure any other questions at all
well one thing I would like to add to
your comments on even ask questions
because I always had many similar
mentors from my university times and the
two mentors when freedom is from my high
school and one of them is from my
University and especially from the guy a
mr. Kerem a Karen we have a relationship
for more than three years three whole
years uninterrupted and I think if this
happened because a GE we unlocked how to
I think that we called the VR cords now
we explored how I can raise well add
value to his life for example I know his
interests and I I research the and find
the many things about his interests and
share whenever I find find them I
comment on the recent lifetimes that
might interest him
and share my ideas so that he also can
understand my J how my generation thinks
about those things around the world
because we have a generation difference
and also he has two daughters they who
are younger than me and I also give
advices for their career and school
development so that he can learn more
recent things the recent developments
about his duties daughter's environment
so we bought hey hey we see value from
each other so that's yeah
continues can hear beautifully
beautifully said I think you are
bringing up something that's important
for everybody to know networking why's
that when you are networking it's all
though arena I said that you need the
mindset that you're interviewing which
is true because just starting to get
this
networking is most successful not when
you're asking but when you're figuring
out how to connect how to give what you
can do for them to that solidifies the
connection basically touching big people
when you have no problems whatsoever but
everything's going great you know and
you will just share your something
lovely that's going on these are the
things that make connections deeper and
can you're a wonderful example thank you
and I have another question if you have
a little bit time I'm trying to change
my years and so my personal brand is
reflecting a little bit different from
my background pull into my future and
I'm not really quite sure about how to
support my current personal Libra brand
for for the job that I'm looking for
okay so what is the difference what or
what do you see is the difference for
where you're going to
you would like I would like to work for
applications so I chose the no degree of
AI product major and basically transform
transfer me may be moving from project
management to product management with
another within another domain okay
I've always been working for the retail
industry domain now I'm moving into
technology applications and product
management specifically product owner I
would like to become so there is a
little bit discrepancy between those
kinds of personal brands and I'm not
really sure about how I can support my
always background
first of all just so you know my
impression of it is actually it's all
your just wanting more ownership it's
all kind of the same thing I always see
that they would like to have the exact
same experience before sometimes it's
about the experience sometimes it's
about the wording also so for example in
product management some of the wording
they use is like Road mapping right as
opposed to strategic thinking
that roadmap is a keyword generally in
product management jobs that you've had
experience with that so some of what
you're trying to do is you're trying to
sync up the wording the terminology that
they're using to terminology that you
may be using from your old area from
project management basically versus
management so that's one aspect of it is
helping them by translating it into the
language that they are looking for on a
very practical level with resumes we're
talking about keywords and we're talking
about computers reading these things or
human beings and all they're looking for
are keywords they're looking for the
right keywords you can't let them
interpret for you you've got to give
them as much of a sync as as possible
when you described what you are moving
towards what I heard is I've taken on a
new tool and I want to have fuller
ownership from the beginning to end of a
project in the technology space rather
than retail space is that about right
yes okay it's not it's not a big it's
not a big stretch
career-wise we're not we're not pivoting
hugely where you're going with things
but it is important that you use the
words that they understand and a son and
as associated with product management in
the description of what your
achievements are
yeah I think I'm trying to do that
actually but I'm not sure that I'm doing
it correctly yes I do one on one I have
a tool you can use and it's it's there
are definitely ways you can do it and
and figure it out whether you're in sync
or not so let's say I just figured out
how to communicate my new personal brand
I figured out discovered it but I'm not
sure if we should simply tell the the
exercise like thing to the interviewers
or should we
they just imply them so I I gave a
format for us to play with okay I'm not
saying this that needs to be how you
presented what it what I wanted it to do
was touch on some of the ideas for you
to define and and to wordsmith basically
and to find words to hang your
description off of and so that when you
made interviewers you're not the main
thing is you're not giving them your
resume which they have in front of them
in a sense you're giving them maybe a
highlight like you had a marvelous story
about Unilever right that that story was
an example of something greater about
you Kinnear
and you want to express what that
greater thing is so that they know this
is what I'm getting with Kinnear I am
getting an accuracy guru you know who is
just all over it and and he did this
with retail and now he wants to do at
NIT and he's like obsessed with
technology
okay now I have some impression you know
that that's different than that I don't
care where you went from place to place
in a sense i what i care is what is what
is driving you what you're passionate
about and how you're bringing that to
people you know whether it be in one
domain or another and how you're tying
that together for them as a story about
yourself
so wording that I put no not not
important the ideas of what's driving
you getting to the heart of that and
sharing that and sharing a little story
around it and using a Unilever as the
example perhaps you know wordsmithing
that to be succinct is is is good
you're welcome
anybody else thank you very much for
joining today and and for being open
enough also to share your stories and
and and go through this together I know
this is not easy at all
to do once you have it I think it's a
lot of like it'll feel like oh of course
you know I've got it but but it's very
it's challenging to do because it takes
looking at yourself being honest about
it and and then in a sense not
exaggerating it but deciding that's the
thing you could have also said I'm a
great cook but I'm a bit I'm you know
and an amazing meticulous cook and this
is the example of how I'm really
accurate you know there there are
different ways of telling these same
stories and different things too to play
on you have to find the one that's most
comfortable for you but that
communicates really what they're gonna
get from you worker wise value was okay
thank you I hope to see you all again
and maybe do some career coaching if we
if we get a chance as well okay have a
wonderful night or day everybody